hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i had a members asked me
if i wanted to test these dirt cheap rca
cables uh this is an aftermarket one
from company called recon
that they sold on on the shelves in the
old days when radio shack was around and
different retailers were around uh i
found them on the ebay two for four
dollars so about two dollars for each uh
it looks like one of these
we used to get a lot of these in thrown
in audio equipment some companies still
do that today
they're very very thin not fashionable
like the new ones that we have and
question is how well do they perform are
there any losses in a cable like this or
not
so i thought i'd do a quick assessment
of that uh by jumping right into the
measurements
um for testing this time i i uh put my
audio precision analyzer in what is
called the loopback mode meaning there's
a relay internally connects input to the
output so
it's the least lossy way of of
transmitting input to the output i set
the voltage to 2 volts which is the
nominal voltage we get on rca cables
and we see that the exceptional
performance of this audio analyzer in
that the distortion is as low as almost
150 db
and this noise dominated to about 121 db
and that's 60 better than threshold of
hearing so
uh performance is just superb as you
would expect from a 30 000 instrument
i then connected this cable to it
intuitively like i said you would think
oh there's going to be some losses well
there isn't the exact same volt 2 volts
and 1.99 which is what we got two volts
of 1.91 so there's no dc losses or
straight losses uh no distortions added
the you know spike is still down to -150
the noise is down
in here so absolutely no change
some people complain and say that test
is at one kilohertz what if you know
it's not music okay well i've got music
in the form of 32 tones
that i can run that i usually put as
part of a lot of my tests
we run that with the loopback mode of
the audio precision analyzer and
basically this is the desired signal and
everything down here in the form of what
we call grass is noise and distortion
it's down about minus 130 db which is
about 21 to 22 bits so extremely good uh
distortion free range and when i plug in
this three foot cable i get i tend to go
performance indeed in the measurement
tool i can overlay these two and once i
do that the colors blend and you can't
tell one from the other
sometimes people complain that say that
well you're not testing at higher
frequencies even though we don't hear
them what value they have i don't know
but i do have a test that goes all the
way up to 90 kilohertz so four and a
half times the audible
range and then i test from 20 hertz to
20 kilos so the analyzer generating step
set of frequencies um starts from right
it goes to the left in this test so it
goes from 20 kilos all the way down 20
hertz
again whether i have the analyzer in
this loopback mode or i have it on
with this
cheap little cable performance identical
about this time somebody will complain
that oh there's some happening in timing
domain the rise time matters slow rate
matters so says all right i'll go ahead
and create a test for that
and here i set up the measurement
bandwidth to be 1 megahertz so about 25
times the audible band
and generally there's one killer
square wave and really zoomed in so it
takes this entire display so we can see
these little nuances in the value as it
changes
and this time i did overlay the two
measurements the loopback and and
the racket on cable and as you can see
the pixels land right on top of each
other there's zero difference in rise
time ringing or any other effect so
every way we test this this cable is
going to perform exceptionally well
now if you took this cable and made it
you know 10 meters or 20 30 feet you are
going to have problems because the
shield impedance becomes uh higher and
there's more
voltage drop across it and the higher
that drop is the more ground loops you
can get um and i haven't tested this one
you may be more prone to picking up
noise although i'll tell you and this
such a short length is not going to have
anything else close to it the generates
enough of a magnetic or
or uh
or a field to induce on this thing to
matter uh but again you have a long
cable it may make a difference so the
point isn't that this is the cable you
want to go buy you know but if you have
it and this is what you need you know
sitting around don't feel bad about
using it i use this uh amazon basics
cable which i think i bought for ten
dollars i've reviewed that on on the
forum you can see his performance also
just as good as this one it's six foot
long it's thick and nice and flexible
and i've abused this to death in that
i've plugged and unplugged it a thousand
times eventually one of the outer shells
got a little loose so i just squeezed it
with a plier and it's tight again it's
gold-plated and uh feels really great so
10 so the point isn't that you know
again you need to go by you should go
buy these things but if you have them
use them if anybody really kills you
point it to my review and say hey look
it makes no difference at all
performance is still superb uh
given you know the actual bandwidth and
capability of this cable is far above
audioband that's why it doesn't make a
difference when we make it so cheap and
thick
okay i'm trying to keep this video short
so i can do more of these quicky reviews
hopefully you got something out of it
see you in the future one bye